no
c
come hai fatto
a te
come potete vedere salotto noi siamo
piccolini vedete che cosa ci ha eletto
chi trova più pop hit ceco più belle
vita oggi siamo io team arancione e blu
per chi votate particola giorni o per
timbro evaderne completo di tiri comodi
la sauber mi piace questo però è di
siamo subito la frana è bellissimo
scoppiare le bolle dei papi qua io ho
già trovato un po pitt che questo nero
da cui abbiamo iniziato dov'è finito
d'italia sono pennello ha preso il pop
hit unicorno
ecco l'ho preso anch'io ho quasi un
cagnolino che carino c'è scritto trova
noi siamo piccolini vedete il di fano
gigante quindi vi siamo in miniatura che
career and one ho trovato un beat lo
avete visto
il pop il treno o no lei prezzo anche tu
no non l'ho preso io mi hai rubato
a questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace fare una seconda forte parte
quindi lasciate un po trovato il bovino
quarto ventole allora ho preso pure io
già a quanti punti 6 a 3
anch'io preferivo il 34 wow
adoro questa ambientazione perché tutto
zigiotto tale salito là sopra
vi piace il mio nuovo ospita arancione e
ho le orecchie da volpe ma io sparito
capitale ragione sul tavolo
preso l'altro pop hit della forma di
penna per una rotta in
quella forma di casco no vabbè portate
si è caduta in acqua qui rapidamente il
pop hit
esse sono al 90 da fuori dall'acquario
io sono e 4 pop eater e o cinque ha
trovato un altro
giuridico per presentare volta che vi
pare farà il mio schermo perché la fede
cerchiamo di chiudere vitale dentro
all'acquario cosa impara signora fa io
sono a 7 punti comunque ehi guarda che
qua sentivo per pezzo 3 al 5
[Musica]
ho vinto il premio living room
wow ho preso tutti compreso 8 pop hit no
cioè nel senso sono uscito fuori
dall'aula lecito si sono in sardinia
fatto uscire dalla mente te lo dico ma
che uscire dalla porta
acqua si può passare se hai preso 7 po
pd ho preso sette bulli del posto
pastori ecco vitale
alright o copiare non seguirmi votato io
più punti di deposito di quanti capitali
trovarne uno meno che meno belle ma
capita tribunali ho trovato un altro io
sono a 96 pp trono
forse un po fitto delfino sono dieci
compito ho preso abbiamo in bagno ho
preso il pop il tuffo ma cosa ci fai nel
cestino
per passare al prossimo state dobbiamo
prendere 14 pon internet e allora non
sono pochi
che carino è così trovato nome l'ho
trovata io a nome copite tu a 11 come è
fatto trovare latina
bravo vediamo stato il gabinetto se
qualcosa
non c'è niente neanche nel lavandino se
niente beh mi devo lavare si dice no non
c'e niente qua forse nell'altro
lavandino
c'è un po bitonale cestino che cosa del
pop e tuffo
ma potrò prendere quel pop hit là sopra
dove vediamo noi con un panno e diamo
vita prima si aggirava qua intorno
ritrovato viene
non è un mai visto il poco piede
non erano il posto a
c'è sapone shampoo sono sullo specchio
e questo ha trovato non ce l'avevo vito
tartaruga
si no
che bello dove siamo adesso facciamo
alcuna che balo giorgio il posto
preferito di vitale la cucina ua un po
pitt passo dove trovato aspetto il roll
over ma tanto mi stai seguendo quindi
sicuramente lo trovi solo trovato
vediamo vitale quanti ne troverà che
cos'era questo telegiornale ne ho
trovato uno ho trovato il pop hit
patatine fritte o lo voglio anch'io dove
ero qui sopra vicino al computer c'è
qualcosa posso
sembrata dei topi sono le trappole per
topi e c'è anche un ristorante o paure a
toccare le trappole che mi spiace
no ecco vitale che sta rubando la mia
idea quando nella trappola purtoppo
speriamo che le trappole lo spia cichino
anno perché io sono più bravo
si è sentito
topolino che carino ecco vitale ok piano
piano questa mostra vitale blu
io voglio salire a qui sul tavolo messo
la cucina la ipocrite patatine e quello
l'avevo trovato già si bruci monigo
m e nel resto a salire sorpreso però un
marmo ei vado italy pubblico c'è
qualcosa sto parsi un po pitt ma come
faccio sparire forse ho capito di sales
è riuscito
va beh io adesso stai colpo minò un po
più traffico lo voglio e una mela poi
grazie per l'idea vincente
è giusto perché questo stop
aiuto bisogna incastrato che bello
essere basta fra nella cucina sapete chi
adora no anzi miniatura che sembra
celato nel tostapane
se qualcuno qua che ci sta guardando
no io ho capito forse c'è un buco qua
nel lavandino vedi per uscire fuori
dentro
e allora bisogna salire 4 proprio ora
dovete andare quindi sul tavolo ci sono
delle banane profit e come faremo stati
ri sul tavolo con la ricorsa
a guidare ha provato a smontare lavoro 0
il sito che se ci mettiamo questo il
cucchiaio tipo 1 facciamo tipo catapulta
uno si mette dall'altro l'altro salta
sopra potremo provare non pensa che
funzioni ma proviamo come si fa a salire
sul no ancora non solo
allora se noi prendiamo la rincorsa
dalla padella
al primo tempo del dolce che non c'erano
meno anche talento metto per passare al
prossimo
voto che io riprovo con quello in frigo
perché non c'è modo di salire sul tavolo
è difficilissimo questo pochi io invece
mi concentro per staccare qualche altro
posto ce lo sforzo dei vigilanti e
riuscire a saltare passeggiate il tempo
marmi tale successo
lasciate un mi piace per portargli
fortuna c'è un conto non solo
prossimo vogliamo vedere un politico che
se si aspetta è troppo divertente questo
gioco 3 siamo in bagno di nuovo sei una
freccia lì che ci dice di entrare nella
tana
gabinetto ti paghi ci sono qui
ma entra primato almeno mi dici sì è
sporco non vado
e uscita fuori
casa il pop hit racchetta
ovviamente sono tutti a tema
dove stiamo sei fuori la fornitura e
allora le foglie è diventata una sorta
di skype room guarda dobbiamo saltare
che bello no
e tutti zona sopra mi sta scoppiando
tutte no ma anche questo fa punto è vero
perdente volevo dire adesso nei punti
vendita
per scoppiare tutte
si è nascosto qua vediamo poi
sappiamo vitale vi sta inseguendo
quanti popizze
fantasma io sono a 24 pop eater a 23 ma
lo so per prendere anch'io quel pop hit
fantasma
pistoia 28 profit siamo 24 perché ma
salire qua adoro questo gioco bene di
frodo vengono ho trovato il pop hit
batman 270 no se le banche passano 2
dobbiamo fare un po di giri a queste
dobbiamo salire la sto brave di lecce
una freccia dobbiamo andare lì e ci tele
trasporterà sopra vediamo via torniamo
indietro scoppiamo altre ball
buttata giù come sempre ma lo sapete che
vitale cane sempre ci stiamo andando
molto vicino a cadere guarda
emma mi ha teletrasportato nuovamente ma
forse gli altri compiti sono qua a
trovarli qua
dovevamo prima cercare i pop hit forze
poi venire qui nelle fognature richiama
se c'è o visto qualcosa e trovato
qualcosa felice qualcosa fa dopo la
vertenza e di caffè che vediamo
mai fatto a meno ma che brutta il 3
tempo finendo forse qualcosa in cui non
siamo partiti davvero vi diamo
qualcosa di nuovo ecco c'è qualcosa qua
che però costerà una macabra up e o
insetto posso passare al prossimo 6 ma
se il voltaggio tu viva superiamo di
tanto non hai trovato con di superarlo a
sfondare copione nostro modulo fa mi ha
inseguito e ora troverà il vento meno
trovato vediamo se dobbiamo dare prima
il prossimo page canto continua da
esplorare ma che ritrovo degli altri pop
prossimo dei dove stiamo di nuovo nel
gabinetto da ci credo fatto risalendo
dal gabinetto come fatto e ora dove
finiremo ma che schifo il ragazzo
era a terra più perfetto grafico che
stiamo fuori casa io più di 123 pop hit
scoppiati quest'anno bolle non potete
vabbè bolle scoppiano ho trovato il
point quadrato che cosa hai una macchia
stiamo nel garage
macchina va preso un bello non ha
maturato bit che sta girando
capite stella con vitale dobbiamo
superarlo
team arancione è vero e giusto ero io in
vantaggio con trovate un po peter zago
nome possa dire qua vediamo che cosa c'è
fu pizzo fiocchetto che carino ma di
piano io ho trentadue tonno anzi 33 ea
tornare trovato non ci credo come fai a
stare sempre uno più avanti di me devo
cadere non devo cadere anche per aiuto
come faccio a dire questo processo e
sono riuscito a salire sulla scala
richter
io già sto avanti guarda sto facciamo
andare ma devo raggiungere vitale dove
stai correndo te lo dico sennò addio
salvati io guardo arrivata soprattutto
il 33 si
è arrivato il papi dove davvero amiamo
la cocaina
quanti pubbliche ci vogliono per il
prossimo che non l'ho visto dobbiamo
trovarlo il prossimo state so che li ho
trovati tutti
usiamo anche bello da te lo dicono
guardare con minore dove mi trovo area
temi afferma ho capito dove ho trovato
fa siamo a 35 anche tu hai un passaggio
per il prossimo stage forse fuori ho
capito forse è qui dobbiamo salire in
quelle travi ii e uscire può capito come
fare ci teniamo qua io sono fuori da
fare anche le immagini che ho detto io
però come pare e allora tanto ora ti
raggiungo
un sì c'è il passaggio siamo nel
giardino che bello è troppo bello e
racconta così gigante al 3 minuto ci
vogliono 35 fidget se quindi ce li
abbiamo
nella camera da letto
ci sono un sacco di giochi ho visto per
poter passare anche cammino o pop hit
cupcake
[Musica]
ok ok grazie a noi con l'altro ce n'è
uno nel cassetto invitare di segue
tengono è vero però che i casi cadrai no
è caduta non ho quindi non c'erano copit
li bene allora vuol dire che dovrebbe
avere altre parti riuscire a trovare
qualcosa meno pop hit
razzo dove trovato non ci credo non l'ho
visto guardate da qua si vede un altro
po pitt laggiù dentro l'auto ha preso
quello pop eater robot che a 39 viso
tutto pazzini e mancano a te ne mancano
tre se non sbaglio ma come hai fatto a
salire la sopra c'è un po più quel saprà
come fatto fallire forse ho capito forse
l'ho capito anch'io
nel cassetto davvero non ha visto che se
il pop hit cavallo hobbit gatto quanti
ci voleva a 42 42
no non so neanch'io come ho fatto a
salire qua sopra
nei cassetti
ho capito dove l'ultimo momento
manent presto sbrighiamoci dobbiamo
superare vitale e per giorni ha superato
i demo bizzare dopo leggerci uscita
fuori dal cappello
c'è un po pitt qua sopra il cactus ma è
difficilissimo fumo nero sopra sul
rimasto troppo indietro
ecco un altro po pitt slovenia os 3.0 43
io sono ancora 41 le soprese una
maglietta pensa che carino saliamo
evviva abbiamo superato abitante non
riesco ad andare avanti in questo stesso
ammette maglietta gatti vanità allora sì
un po busco ha detto a ecco vitale un po
adesso b copia no preso il topix fragola
comincerò gnocchi un po pitt fragola
puppet e girasole a quanti sera 46 io
sono solo 43 della piscina preso per
fare ma io ho fatto così pari ai
sospetti mentre di seguirvi on sto
seguendo le abitudini seguirmi
45 di sto raggiungendo limone si
vogliono 49 fidget c'è 49 pop hit come
saranno gli altri una maglietta
dove era quel passaggio segreto di
copione ho preso la carota ora ho capito
dove trovare l'ultimo pop hit ma è
difficilissimo da prendere il sole nel
cartoon nel cactus
ce l'ho con non credo ci sia un attacco
di tempo perché cade in continuazione
ballo minutolo fondo apprezzati come il
prossimo stage 9 maggio stiamo ancora il
giardino il parco giochi prima o poi
trovato grazie
wow c'è un po pt in un'altalena dovrà
salire sull'altare dalla sopra nel
frattempo vitale ancora questo giocato
al gatto da questo per cactus villalta
troviamo una scorciatoia come faccio a
prendere questa sull'altalena dovrò
buttarmi
59 fatto un pit anguria dai puoi farcela
anche tu leggo
solo successivo tocca vedo
bisogna saltare il parco giochi gigante
troppo bello dinosaur
no me ne manca solo uno per passare al
prossimo stage devo superare mica mi sto
disperando su questo cactus ovvero
vitale mio piedone spina e pero bloccato
il cat
poverino c'è qualcosa qua
era un ascolto circa si no come fai ad
essere così in avanti ripresa ei sei
gioco top secret di incamerare appreso
di infobuild cactus e va bene che aiuto
visto che dietro della carriera devi
salire sopra sopra e poi buttati
bartalena giusta tu sei l'aspirapolvere
quello robot stai attenta magari con la
visita alla pop hit minion che carino
dentro una teiera ho trovato questo non
questo è un salotto giapponese c'è il
tavolo per terra con l'esp e proviamo a
salire sulla spira polvere malefica wow
ne mancano ancora 5 fingeva un
aspirapolvere mi ha trasportato qua sul
tavolo il primo torta no torta cosa devo
sbrigarmi devo sbrigarmi lo voglio
proviamo a risalire sulla spira polvere
magari mi porta da qualche altra parte è
il fermarsi qua qua ok che bello essere
miniatura via no pensavo mi trasporta se
qua ma invece
lei il ritiro block è riuscita
ho trovato un passaggio segreto ovvero
adesso ci sono anch'io qui a matri toni
giusti sbrigarmi dovere questo passaggio
segreto so che cosa c'è un teschio
laggiù è molto invitante strano a si può
uscire perché c'è un teschio lì vabbè
proviamo andare ma perché c'è la lava
attenta come facciamo allora prendere
quel pop hit
beh io provo a buttarmi
ho sentito il rumore di sfugge alla
mente o sbaglio mi mancano ancora tre
popit dove saranno tipo se c'è qualcosa
qua si libreria sera è il pop hit di
peppa pig ci sono altri giocatori
vediamo come riescono a passare qua no è
celebrata in frase nata qualcuno ha
messo un po pitt quanto è riuscito a
passare forse così
quindi io posso che dirti interessante
vai vai corri wow
perché se lo guardavo il tetto che bello
aver messo questo può più no tav
copiando il pop hit di un altro
giocatore il pop hit che avevo messo è
ancora qua
piano piano b
ce l'ho fatta quindi questo era il
trucco vieni a 62 a favore ma anche farò
un altro vado il passaggio segreto
capitale tappeti sbrighi c'è ancora il
mio pop heatley nella lavato tra i
liquori come ponte ei ma quel cassetto
si apre quindi sicuro mi ha detto di qua
come fatto da pirlo il cassetto che ci
ha provato in mille modi e
anita giusto per dirti che ti ho
raggiunto adesso a 63 sappiamo di nuovo
pari sbrighiamo dove siamo adesso non me
lo passò niente qua succede non c'è
niente
definito stiamo nel giardino di notte
stile halloween
che cos'è questo motore
non premere il bottone super migliaccio
malefico allora io voglio vincere se un
po pt invece
kerber tessuto maggio ok ragazzi questo
è l'ultimo states c'è quindi chi
riuscirà per primo a passare attraverso
quella porta vincerà vero oggi come in
realtà ci sono altri stage ma se
continuiamo fino alla fine del gioco
questo video e quindi passate mi piace
se questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace faremo anche la seconda parte ma
ora proviamo a vincere ho trovato
proviamo a cadere nel calderone
sigo
strega sapete che hanno qui nella mia
testa è capita
no che succede sono stato preso da un
ragno
ma come si è morso bragno
subito chi il ragno pelosissimo attento
perché
ho capito devo passare velocemente
freddo
vediamo che evita l'evento ci credo se
java c i catto narrano midolo sto
prendendo anch'io
devo vincere devo vincere la prima parte
di questa caccia ai papi testa a testa
adesso e dove devo andare con l'abito
roberta come faccia uscire 26 mente lo
dico tu quanti pupi 66 siamo pari no
penso di sapere dove andare per prendere
degli altri pochezza aiuta a vitale
dietro
militari vi sta raggiungendo lo faccio
come fatto contro papa non ci credo come
fatto ieri
[Musica]
quasi un albero stranissimo sembra il
platano picchiatore di harry potter la
caa
sicurezza tra qualcosa fa di uno già
preso quello che li ha
no se il battage issimo deve mancare
solo due vediamo se da fare insomma
vedere dove sono a mettere invece si
corre infatti youtube ha un'idea forse
qua dove escono i mostri
aiuto al capo no no copiare
motore sono copiate ce ne mancano due
chili troverà per primo a me ne manca
solo uno come hai fatto trovare altro
non ci credo
chi vince l'abbiamo dove evitare vediamo
dove è andato
hp ritrovato decreto l'ha trovato prima
pagina de non siamo pari inoltre
lo troverò adesso per primo ho avuto
un'idea non guardare non porta ho avuto
un'idea ma non so se funzionerà vediamo
ebbene io volevo appoggiarlo qua non li
no non funziona però che il poeta
schiacciato questa bolla per fare signor
mostre magari c'era un po più tela
dentro fare un voto può andare bene ci
manca solo all 1 ei aspetta e io qui
però trovato un passaggio segreto più
destro
no
voto qui era nascosto
quadrato
per uno storico
prova per team arancione volte volete
vederlo secondo partono estate un baby
mi piace ora vi lasciamo quattro case
linee su cui applicare per vedere i
nostri altri video e cade su collego
preferite
ciao